[Musik]
was ihr hier seht ist unglaublich klein
so klein dass man es mit normalem licht
gar nicht sehen könnte es sind milben
staubkörner einzeller und andere objekte
die man in so einer detailtiefe nur auf
diese art und weise beobachten kann
denn sie wurden mit einem
elektronenmikroskop aufgenommen
für dieses video war ich wieder zu
besuch bei mini truck der nanotruck hat
ein kleines mobiles
rasterelektronenmikroskop mit dem man
selber experimentieren und dinge
untersuchen kann
dänemark ist quasi eine fahrende zukunft
ausstellung in der man ganz vieles
selber ausprobieren und entdecken kann
es gibt wohl reality brillen ein roboter
und sogar eine spritze ohne nadel alles
was mit der zukunft zu tun hat eben aber
ich schaue mir heute das
rasterelektronenmikroskop an
und da das doch ein wenig komplizierter
zu bedienen ist habe ich dabei hilfe
bekommen mein name ist doch eine clique
boston ich bin promovierter biologe ich
hier in not rang habe pflanzen
biotechnologie studiert an der leibniz
universität hannover und dann in diesem
fall auch promoviert möchte ich hier im
inselrat einfach mal zeigen was wir
zurzeit für ideen und deutschland haben
in high tech bereich und den leuten die
chance geben diese ideen diese exponate
diese visionen auch sehen zu können okay
aufnahmen von einem elektronenmikroskop
haben wahrscheinlich alles schon mal
gesehen aber wie funktioniert so was
eigentlich das hier ist ein
rasterelektronenmikroskop und es
arbeitet mit einem elektronenstrahl der
stück für stück über die probe fährt die
probe ist das was wir untersuchen wollen
in meinem fall war es etwas das ich
mitgebracht habe eine schallplatte
elektronen können viel präziser
gebündelt werden als sichtbares licht
denn mit sichtbarem licht kann man nur
dinge erkennen die halb so groß sind wie
die wellenlänge des lichts das verwendet
wird das heißt im normalfall das alles
unter 200 nanometer quasi unsichtbar ist
aber auch da gibt es einen trick mit dem
man das umgehen kann
für diesen trick hat professor doktor
stephan hält 2014 einen nobelpreis
erhalten und ich erkläre in diesem video
wie das funktioniert nun aber zurück zu
unserem elektronenstrahlen die
elektronen werden durch magnete
gebündelt und mit einer beschleunigung
spannung auf die probe geschossen weil
der strahl eine hohe energie hart werden
elektronen aus der probe
herausgeschlagen
diese herausgeschlagen elektronen werden
dann von einem geladenen detektor
angezogen und gezählt
je mehr elektronen erkannt werden desto
heller wird der punkt an dieser stelle
von der software eingefärbt das liegt
daran dass mehr elektronen
herausgeschlagen werden wenn der strahl
gerade an eine oberfläche trifft
wie bei einem normalen foto werden so
unterschiedliche winkel und oberflächen
auch unterschiedlich belichtet jetzt
lenken die magnete den elektronenstrahl
an eine stelle die ein kleines bisschen
weiter rechts ist und das ganze
prozedere würde wiederholt so ergibt
sich nach und nach ein bild von der
probe und deswegen heißt es auch
rasterelektronenmikroskop zurück zu
meiner schallplatte
ich wollte nämlich herausfinden wie die
rillen einer schallplatte unter dem
elektronenmikroskop aussehen und diese
mit einer cd vergleichen
analoge musik gegen digitale allerdings
hat sich der prozess etwas schwieriger
gestaltet als ursprünglich gedacht habe
zuerst musste eine meiner schallplatten
dran glauben denn die stücke die man auf
den sogenannten proben teller legt
müssen sehr klein sein
dann muss man sich mit einer software
quasi blind über den proben teller
bewegen und die stellen finden die einen
interessieren
das kann schon mal seine zeit dauern
denn die bildwiederholrate ist nicht
sonderlich gut
der raum in dem die probe sich befindet
muss dabei übrigens luftleer sein
deswegen wird immer ein vakuum erzeugt
wenn wir etwas neues in das mikroskop
legen damit der strahl auch nicht
abgelenkt wird damit um unsere wände
geschützt ist weil die sonst sehr
schnell zerstört werden kann
in dem fall ist es aber auch so wenn man
später dann schöne bilder haben möchte
man hat luftmoleküle die im weg sind
dann hat man dort einfach artefakte welt
auch das wird noch mal dazu dass es sehr
lange dauert ein gutes bild zu bekommen
aber nach über einer stunde harte arbeit
ist es endlich passiert wir haben ein
bild gemacht auf dem man die rillen der
schallplatte erkennen kann und dann noch
eins und noch eins
hier entlang gehen die rillen und hier
sieht man sogar die bruchstelle der
platte nach diesem erfolg beflügelt
haben wir sogar noch eine schippe
draufgelegt und ein bild aus einem
winkel geschossen das ist besonders
schwierig das ergebnis ist das wie ich
finde
bisher bester wie kann man sogar
wirklich die höhenunterschiede erkennen
die dann auf dem plattenspieler einen
ton erzeugen
im kontrast dazu steht die cd hier sieht
man ganz regelmäßige muster von
sogenannten pitz und lernens also zu
deutsch in gruben und flächen zwei
grundsätzlich verschiedene ansätze um
dasselbe ergebnis zu erzeugen
elektronenmikroskope wie sie in unis und
forschungseinrichtungen verwendet werden
sind übrigens fast immer größer teurer
nicht wirklich mobil und die proben
dafür müssen aufwendig vorbereitet
werden was wir hier gemacht haben ist
sehr vereinfacht und hat den nachteil
dass wir nicht so hochauflösend und
präzise arbeiten können weil man sich
sonst in den richtig großen
elektronenmikroskopen das ganze
anschauen dann den universitäten oder
den unternehmen dann dauert es manchmal
schon ein tag so eine probe sauber
vorzubereiten damit man danach auch
schöne bilder sehen kann weil man im
bereich der organischen oder in der
orangerie kroos kopie sich das ganze
ankommt ist es noch ein bisschen
komplexer es hat aber auch den vorteil
dass es jeder machen kann wenn ihr
einmal im innotec seid dann könnt ihr
auch etwas ins elektronenmikroskop legen
und coole bilder machen auf jeden fall
etwas was ich euch empfehlen kann
vielen dank an das gesamte team von
innotrek dass wir noch mal bei euch
drehen durften und dass sie uns bei der
produktion des videos unterstützt haben
der truck ist ein projekt des
bundesministeriums für bildung und
forschung und werde jedes jahr bis zu 75
stationen überall in deutschland an
vielleicht kommt ja auch mal in euren er
wo er als nächstes hin fährt das könnt
ihr auf der website nachschauen einen
link dazu findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung danke fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]